and we just played a snippet of the
video that was filmed last night outside
parliament of sakir starma and that mob
and i'm sure it's a clip you will have
seen numerous times today what did you
think when you saw it
it's sickening uh you know i you don't
think any politicians should have to put
up with
what kierstarman experienced uh last
night and you know it is a reflection i
think of the the toxic cocktail of
conspiracy theories smears and lies that
swell swell around our politics now and
i think the choice for all uh
responsible politicians is do we unite
whatever our other differences might be
to push all of that to the margins of
our politics or do we do what boris
johnson did which is almost weaponize
that to make attacks on an opponent and
to do that
in the full knowledge that that can and
does stir up the kind of hatred and
abuse and harassment that kierstarmer
experienced yesterday so this is a
really dangerous moment for our politics
but i think it can also be a positive
moment for our politics if responsible
politicians come together in the right
spirit now i would finally just say that
your credit to keir starman and to david
lammy actually uh who will know more
than most of us about these far-right
attacks for the way they conducted
themselves i have had some experience
personally or being confronted on the
streets by the far right and it's not
pleasant it's deeply unpleasant and i'm
sure they will have been deeply shaken
by it but i think they deserve credit
for the way in which they handled it but
this is a moment to decide that this is
not acceptable in our politics tough
scrutiny of politicians is essential in
our democracy but when that crosses the
line and becomes at the stirring up of
hate and abuse something has gone far
wrong and that's a moment to take a line
in the sand to draw a line in the sand
and say that we cannot allow this to
continue there are calls for boris
johnson to withdraw his comments
completely and apologize downing street
say he has clarified his club comments
and boris johnson uh these are his words
he said uh
after uh initial criticism of his
comments regarding sir kirsten and jimmy
savile he said i want to be very clear
about this because a lot of people have
got hot under the collar and i
understand why let's be absolutely clear
i'm talking not about the leader of the
opposition's personal record when he was
dpp and i totally understand that he had
nothing to do personally with these
decisions i was making a point about his
responsibility for the organization as a
whole i really do want to clarify that
because it is important it's a
clarification
it's not an apology why is it
politicians find sorry
the hardest word
well not all of us do frankly and i
don't think we should all be tainted by
the standards and the behavior of boris
johnson and the the
smear that he hurled at kyo starman in
the house of commons last week frankly
has been compounded by the weasel words
that you have
just read out from boris johnson you
know he knew what he was doing you know
he's many things but he's not naive and
any politician who chooses to weaponize
a conspiracy theory circulated around
social media by the far right against an
opponent knows what they are doing and
either they are trying to stir up the
kind of hate that flows from that or
they don't care about that being the
consequence and either way that is
behavior that is just unbefitting at
somebody in boris johnson's position if
he has a shred of decency and i
appreciate that may be the flaw in the
argument i'm about to make but he if he
has a single shred of decency he will
withdraw the comments that he made
completely and he will fully
unreservedly unequivocally apologize to
kierstarma and he will join
others in saying that we should hold
each other to account we should have
robust debate in a democracy
but we should all draw the line at
bringing the smears and the lies and the
conspiracy theories of the far right and
the other trolls that populate social
media into the mainstream of our
democracy because if we allow that to
happen it's like battery acid that will
corrode
trust in our politics and corrode the
very fabric of our democracy and frankly
you know boris johnson's in a whole of
his own making right now
but it is not going to reflect well on
him if in order to try to get himself
out of that hole he's prepared to throw
the whole of our democracy to the wheels
in the process okay i just want to talk
to you about the difference between um
taking personal responsibility and
accountability for something and being
the leader who takes collective
responsibility because there's been a
lot of talk about that recently whether
people should apologize for personal
actions or actions that are taken by an
organization such as the the government
or the tory party and the leaders should
take um accountability for that because
there are a lot of people that will say
you can't pick and choose sakirstama has
taken personal credit for cps um
prosecutions for things that happened in
the organization that he wasn't
personally involved in so a lot of
people will say what's the difference
why would he not take responsibility for
this decision that wasn't personal but
he did head up the organization that did
make that decision do you want to put
that issue to bed for us because that's
the argument that a lot of people will
put to what you're saying today
yeah look
leaders and i'm a leader of a government
leader of a party i know that it comes
with the territory to have to take
overall responsibility for things that
you are not personally involved in are
responsible for and i'm pretty sure
kirsten understands that as well but you
know that's what
boris johnson and the tories are some
tories kids to their credits some of
them are not going along with this one
is to think was the issue at stake and
all i would suggest to people making
that argument is go back and look at
what boris johnson actually said in the
house of commons last week and he didn't
say to keir starmer you were in charge
of the uh the crown prosecution service
at the time the decisions about jimmy
savile were made he said and i don't
have it in front of me so i may be
slightly paraphrasing here but he said
something along the lines of you spend
all of your time prosecuting journalists
and not prosecuting at jimmy savile at
the clear implication being that these
were decisions that kierstarmer had
taken personally and not just that there
were decisions that were taken by an
organization that he was in charge of i
come back to this we can all and the
tories and boris johnson want to dance
in the head of these pins right now but
he knew what he was doing he was facing
a really tough encounter in the house of
commons and rightly and properly so
given the backdrop to this was the
sugary report and he decided to you know
throw the dead cat on the table to try
to distract people's attention with a
baseless smear on the integrity and the
character of keir starmar and that is
what is so despicable and in order to do
that he went to the you know deepest
darkest recesses of social media and
took out a far-right conspiracy theory
lie smear call it what you want that's
what it was about and boris johnson knew
that that is what he was doing and you
know i'm in a different political party
to kierstarma there are many many things
i disagree with kiera starmaron i'll
argue over things with kirsten he'll
argue with me but this is my central
point here if we care about democracy
then decent politicians regardless of
what divides us have to be able to come
together in defense of the fundamental
norms and basic decency in our politics
because if we lose that then we lose
everything
and that is too big a price to pay for
boris johnson to try unsuccessfully as
it happened to wriggle off a hook that
he had put himself on
um just finally while we have you first
minister you have a perspective that the
majority of people don't have in terms
of being a leader you are first minister
of scotland boris johnson is is the
prime minister um
what's it like to think about leaving a
job like that because the criticism of
boris johnson is that he will not resign
where many people think he should many
people think this is a tipping point but
he has been unequivocal he will not be
resigning how difficult is it to make
that kind of decision
well i've not had to make that decision
but i've had to contemplate it and i'll
come back to that in a second but before
i do the kind of job i have the job
boris johnson has
these are privileges they're not
entitlements nobody is entitled to be
first minister or prime minister um and
there are jobs that you do and we all
make mistakes in the course of it none
of us are perfect but there are jobs
that we do to further the interests of
the people we serve not to further our
own interests and so i think it is
incumbent on everybody holding a
position like this that you are prepared
to contemplate when it might be the
right time for you to meet that office
and you know my own personal experience
this time last year i was being accused
in a completely different context of
having breached the ministerial code i
should say i was found by an independent
advisor and in an independent report not
to have breached the ministerial code
but while that was ongoing i had within
myself to ask myself some serious
questions and i came to the conclusion
in my mind that had i been deemed to
have breached the ministerial code i
didn't think i had but if an independent
person had said i had then in the
interest of the office i hold and in the
interest of the country i at that point
would have resigned i'm sure it would
have been really difficult and i'm glad
that didn't come to pass but these
responsibilities are heavy
responsibilities
and they require all of us in these
offices to contemplate things that
perhaps others might think
is is difficult to imagine so boris
johnson has to fundamentally think about
the interests of the country he has
discredited and he has you know the
sugary report constrained though it was
was pretty brutal in its conclusions
about lack of leadership i i don't think
it is possible to come to a conclusion
other than that he has
serially um
and seriously misled the house of
commons um and at a time of mounting
crisis for the country we're not quite
out of the covert pandemic yet cost of
living pressures increasing real
problems for people the length and
breadth of the country
they need a prime minister the uk needs
a prime minister that isn't completely
consumed by these problems of his own
position and therefore i think if boris
johnson has decency and integrity
however difficult it may be he will
reach the conclusion that the time is
right for him to step aside